as a reported death toll in this country
from the coronavirus soars past seventy
one thousand new human trials for a
possible vaccine are underway our David
agus joins us now from Los Angeles with
more dr. agus good morning so Pfizer is
one of the companies involved in these
trials beginning here in the United
States the method they're using has
never brought a vaccine to market
successfully so how promising is it
they're using what we call an RNA
vaccine so it's not a piece of the virus
that's classically used it's actually
the instructions for the virus or RNA
and they're injected and then the body
the human body makes the protein in an
immune response attacks the protein and
hopefully prevents the virus Pfizer is
being clever is they're taking four
parts of the spike protein and putting
that into four separate vaccine to four
shots on goal in the beginning in
several hundred patients to see if you
can make a good enough immune response
to go to a much larger trial to
hopefully prevent the virus all right
four shots on goal I like the sound of
that the timetable for this vaccine is
as soon as the fall that's possible what
needs to happen for that to get done how
likely is it well Toni every step has to
work so initially one of those four have
to give a good enough immune response
that it can provide AB unity and once
you have that then it could be expanded
to say doesn't really prevent the virus
from getting in each of those take time
to do this is an RNA vaccine so it's
easier and cheaper to scale and make
than a classic vaccine but as you
mentioned it's never been FDA approved a
type of this vaccine so it's a little
bit new and so we're going on new ground
here but there's certainly hope and
potential as there is with several other
vaccine candidates
I pray that one maybe two maybe three of
them will work and we'll have them in
the fall or in December or in January
any time as soon as possible yeah when
people hear about an accelerated
timetable and new methods there can be
some worries so what are the risks of
moving forward in this way and I guess
to sharpen the question how do those
risk compared to the risk of not having
a vaccine at all well not having a
vaccine means we have a continued death
rate in this country which is
unacceptable vaccines historically have
safe and we're doing the safety studies
now some steps were skipped with some of
the vaccines in animal work others had
years of animal work to get the the
vaccine itself ready and so each one of
them have different safety work done and
we'll have going forward there is no way
a vaccine is going forward into patients
in large-scale unless it's proven safe
and so I hope that this works you know
the big variable to me is will the
immune response be strong enough to
prevent the virus and we should know
that for some of the vaccines in the
middle of June all right David quickly I
want to get your reaction to a troubling
headline some emerging research
suggesting that there might be a mutated
strain of the corona virus particularly
here on the East Coast that is more
infectious and more aggressive what's
your reaction to that research
unfortunately it got more headlines that
it should have there are multiple
strains of the virus about 30 in total
this was a strain that became a dominant
strain starting in February in Italy and
then kind of moved to the rest of the
world the researchers in a not yet
reviewed manuscript said well it's more
infectious which is why it became
dominant there's no real evidence of
that there's no evidence that the DNA
changes which always happen in viruses
that the DNA changes will change
response to drugs or vaccines at the
present time so at the present time it's
an observation all right not yet
peer-reviewed important to note David
thank you very much